ich habe eine Nacht im Pol Express in
Finnland auf dem Weg von Helsinki nach
rowanemi in die Stadt des
Weihnachtsmannes übernachtet und so viel
hat es gekostet um ins Finnische
laplland zuelangen kann man natürlich
fliegen wenn man aber Bock auf Abenteuer
hat empfehle ich euch den Pol Express zu
buchen dieser fährt jeden Abend von
Helsinki nach rovanemi und man kann sich
sogar eigene Zimmer BU angekommen am
Bahnhof fuhr der Zug schon ca 20 Minuten
a ein und ich konnte es mir im Abteil
gemütlich machen das Interieur besteht
aus einem Hochbett für zwei Personen und
es gibt sogar teilweise eigene Duschen
das wollte ich natürlich testen um
endlich sagen zu können ich habe schon
mal in einem Zug geduscht das Beste an
der Reise ist jedoch die atemberaubende
Aussicht ich hätte mich die ganzen 12
Stunden der Fahrt vor das Fenster hocken
können um in die durch den Schnee hell
erleuchtete Landschaft zu schauen ein
richtiges Erlebnis und gerade so kurz
vor Weihnachten umso schöner ich habe
noch nie in einem Nachtzug so gut
geschlafen wie hier so sah es am
nächsten Morgen aus kurz mal nach
draußen Steppen bei -14° und ab in den
Restaurantwagen Frühstück holen der Zug
ist natürlich pünktlich in rovanemi am
nördlichen Polarkreis angekommen bezahlt
habe ich gerade mal 160 € für zwei
Personen echt ein Schnäppchen und ich
habe